free men at last a momentous moment not
only for them personally but politically
too
around 900 prisoners will be released as
part of a prisoner swap between Saudi
Arabia and the iran-backed houthis The
Exchange will happen over three days
part of a deal reached in Switzerland
last month
the international committee for the Red
Cross is overseeing the transportation
of these men to Saudi Arabia and Yemen
among those being freed Yemen's Former
Defense Minister and also the brother of
the president the result of negotiations
between the two sides to seek an end to
the near nine-year War I think that the
visit of the Saudi Ambassador has
actually moved this this
prisoner exchange even though I have
seen the clear message to Saudi Arabia
they are ready for a full exchange of
prisoners in both sides which could be
about 15
000 prisoners of course it's a quite
significant step
it's debating the mutual trust between
the legitimate government and Roti and
also paved the way to the peace plan in
Yemen
Yemen's U.N brokered six-month truce
officially ended in October but still
largely holds the recent diplomatic push
comes as the two main players in what is
often called a proxy war have made peace
last month Saudi Arabia and Iran agreed
to end their seven-year diplomatic Rift
and re-establish diplomatic ties in a
deal broken by China in a statement the
U.S Special Envoy for Yemen said that
Yemen is witnessing an unprecedented
opportunity for peace
a significant moment most definitely
however finding common ground between
Saudi Arabia and the houthis for a long
lasting peace will take more work and
more time
Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera